[Music]
[Music]
pilot to Bombardier pilot to Bombardier
planes are overhead pilot the Bombardier
[Music]
WK @ Z the Dutch station
what's happening you bad [ __ ]
it's Tuesday April 19th I me ask your
question who's the captain kirk of your
[ __ ] enterprise you understand
because in my world without being i'll
enter all our i what's happening you bad
[ __ ] uncle Joey here man of
many reefers and have two little [ __ ]
containers at that thing I'm not into a
a different [ __ ] dimension the wife
walk around much with the
chitter-chatter joy let's get right to
the point of this little [ __ ] tape
back tape reefer
oh yeah it's nice that but sun-shining
you had your breakfast you did your
[ __ ] goals and now you're ready is
sitting there we get that down to
somebody's right there if that that's
you [ __ ]
[ __ ] this is from sunset herb
kisses still knocking [ __ ] out
if you're looking for a party package
for tomorrow right here in this
[ __ ]
this is perennials I put an act of Danny
because the other shits in the glass I'm
gonna fall naughty I mean so you don't
gotta step my [ __ ] glass I don't mind
class now I'm gonna mix up my [ __ ]
refract no time understand it looks cool
for people but for me I'm not into being
cool I just want to be [ __ ] that's don't
understand me so get that out of your
[ __ ] way right there I've been up
since like Bendis sakes right plot
smoking reefer get my day ready
but it was just like [ __ ] grandpa's
basement but this man I'm outside good
you'll back the fun inside that's how I
roll [ __ ] teaching John 24/7 [ __ ]
these [ __ ] 4:20 we get the
tattoo of a bud
suddenly they can call me shorty [ __ ]
oh yeah first we don't [ __ ] fire to
the had a big day today and they come
out from the fire where's the smoke
coming from the example the whole thing
I won I did heroin or something last
night and I got a little holders smokers
sneaking out of my little [ __ ]
Hospital gives a [ __ ] jack you gotta be
fill those holes understand
it's Tuesday what you do Monday anything
it's a beautiful [ __ ] day to be alive
in her life is if you [ __ ] up
yesterday
you'll make it up today some kid wasn't
playing on Twitter a bomb blast and I
hope there's a [ __ ] good one
that's why you got mine yeah Mannie Anna
is always a big [ __ ] thing people are
not they not be another mañana but you
make sure there's gonna be another
[ __ ] but ya talking about if you've
not Sesame Street [ __ ] Magana
means tomorrow try to put your par with
the [ __ ] Spanish language I mean you
[ __ ] surrounded your exam
you guys won't hear a few words you're
[ __ ] surrounded the Spanish people
[ __ ] everybody understand Spanish
people every better get the [ __ ] they
don't give a [ __ ] they got a football
[ __ ] country brown tall Apocalypto so
what evil UOP in China and Latin and you
[ __ ] priests the Palast [ __ ]
Halloween kids can you [ __ ] together
[ __ ]
it's April 19 2016 [ __ ] are
dying out there then you wanna hang out
with your little [ __ ] hat down with
stories about what about [ __ ] what
we went to Coachella and got your roses
sucked what are you expect what do you
expect and if three million dollars
that'll give a [ __ ] they just not that
play until the strong hands I hated in
Ferguson but I don't know
it's the corporate lifestyle [ __ ]
any will feeling blood I got you Jitsu I
got acupuncture and I got a meeting and
I got a spot that I hit the [ __ ]
store if you're not doing that it's
Tuesday and I'm gonna [ __ ] my room I'm
getting stoned to the gills with eight
[ __ ] some in the morning who's better
than you guys who's better than us that
we got the [ __ ] boss to come over
here and smoke a [ __ ] but before they
start so we don't give a [ __ ] jack
there's a bit of a flood you're slipping
on already
you understand me just slipping already
who gives a [ __ ] at the end of the day
who's on the grocery line what you
paying for groceries it's you [ __ ]
so what the [ __ ] you sitting there
worried about your [ __ ] [ __ ] friends
would get the [ __ ] out in
me it's not worrying a long time I don't
give a [ __ ] you get up in the morning
you get down
well if you don't make it happen he's
smoked a [ __ ] joint and you plot
mañana the understand that's I'm talking
about you always got my gun my hands ed
she put a final lottery ticket besides
that that's it that's what happened to
him
should we spell another part
abso-fucking-lutely I'm gonna show up
here bother you with a little skinny
flop enjoyment is wrong with these
people
somebody show up show up with two
canisters and there so they tip oh why
does that say you gotta be you want to
be a [ __ ] [ __ ] go drink tea get him
[ __ ] krimpets whatever the [ __ ] to do
with your time
I don't look red for this you know that
I leave another crept the [ __ ] it's
little gives a [ __ ] it's Tuesday you're
here I'm here
well mainly I have taxes they take a lot
of personnel
oh yeah this reef is looking tremendous
waters with the underworld and then I'm
gonna go out there I'm gonna make em all
suck my dick don't even ever see what
happened you know what [ __ ] happened
cuts up a puto is he a [ __ ]
if you don't notice I'm doing not the
believers breathing exercises I smoked
dope Mountain
I want my balls to breathe the [ __ ]
refund you didn't listen to doctor
Belize's podcast last Wednesday just
living not the police could change a
[ __ ] life [ __ ]
Oh bill
Oh jumping up and down integrator who I
exercise when you're walking if you sit
now when I should I breathe out breathe
then the [ __ ] comes out of my mouth was
smooth and observe it
besides that that's it that's all I got
and listen good [ __ ] music today the
- is that like my uncle said but now for
Casper young when I had none of my
diplomatic implica and what that means
keep to yourself
get people confused about the bitch-slap
some telling them in general do a real
German - that sucks dick nothing your so
they come just saying the subs definite
takes away from your time using a plant
may ever sitting to say having your
fingerprints what I do the [ __ ]
nightmare
anyway Buffalo New York Thursday Friday
selling it will [ __ ] wins ready
I'm not Buffalo
just look at Holloway
they had not approved on over there bull
car like me and they'll fight you to the
end the [ __ ] time understand just my
kind no tough guy but I'm going all mean
ain't no punk [ __ ] anyway have a great
[ __ ] day god bless you [ __ ]
well as the pears god a black nor white
through the head to a Chinese we don't
give a [ __ ]
there's something up that it helps us do
this anyway I love you [ __ ] yams
don't the [ __ ] you spend I just did
three bowls of [ __ ] death but you got
a suckers really expect me to be
forgetting my town tonight but give me a
[ __ ] breather I love you guys have a
great day
stayed black I thought like what if they
don't let nobody [ __ ] with you till I
remember they [ __ ] with you
we